Michael knows his Knowles is the host of
the Michael Knowles show and he joins us
now with his reaction morning Michael
Michael good morning so here you have a
school district saying we don't want
objectivity when our children are
learning in these classrooms because the
pro-trump view is racist you know
President Trump has this knack for
making his opponents honest he has the
Democrats admitting that they're
socialists he has many teachers
admitting that their indoctrinating
rather than educating for totalitarians
they always go after education for
progressives the the future is certain
but the past is always changing this is
especially true in the teaching of
history and this is much bigger than one
high school for years and years now the
the left has replaced standard history
books with propaganda like Howard Zinn
as a result of this according to one
survey a third of American Millennials
believe that George W Bush killed more
people than Joseph Stalin the majority
of them can't explain the purpose of the
Bill of Rights according to one survey
just 18% of American students are
proficient in US history there was one
teacher at Newton High School who said
that objectivity is a weapon a
destructive weapon against social
justice this raises an obvious point if
truth is the enemy of social justice
maybe there's something wrong with
social justice the greatest thing about
our country is the differences of
opinion that the ability for all of us
to learn about those and where you learn
them is in school so this is really
alarming when you see something like
this happening Michael how do we change
this because we have you on all the show
all the time on the show and you were so
great talking about Millennials and what
we're facing today how do we move
forward though how do we learn from this
how do we better ourselves how do we
allow for more conversation and more
opinions
well education is the basis here if you
education is the way toward upward
mobility if you teach a child lies
knowingly that is child abuse you should
be liable for that if you're a teacher
who does it you should be fired and this
is basically a massive advertisement for
homeschooling and school choice we need
more choices in the classroom because
otherwise you're just going to breed
ignorant sand in the vacuum of that
ignorance
you're going to get it ideology not
knowledge and Michael in this case we
reached out to the school district in
Newton they have not given us a comment
but the Federalists had a quote from one
of the history teachers I think you
alluded to this a moment ago here's the
full quote a teacher there said I'm
concerned that the call for objectivity
may just inadvertently become the most
effective destructive weapon against
social justice so what in the heck you
know what in the world is going on here
when you have teachers saying we can't
have objectivity that we can't give kids
more than one point of view this is a
full-scale assault on truth beyond just
Newton High School when you look at the
anti-trump so-called march for science
the lead organizer of the March for
science itself says that objectivity
that objective truth universal truth is
really just a fiction of the white male
cisgender hierarchy this is an all-out
assault on truth and communication
because if objective truths break down
if we can't allude to objective
realities then we're just going to be
grunting and screaming and shrieking
interest groups butting up against one
another we see that a lot on the Left
these days but I'm hoping we don't see
it for the whole country